this is now becoming a pattern donald
trump very clearly
does not want to take questions from
reporters right now because the
questions would overwhelmingly be
about his tax returns about his paying
no income taxes for 10 of the last 15
years
about his paying 750 dollars
in federal income taxes in the year he
was elected and in his first year as
president his
exaggerations of the profitability of
his businesses and since donald trump
doesn't want to take the questions
he's just bailing out without taking
questions at public appearances
yesterday trump did a
total propaganda event at the white
house rose garden to talk about
again how great coronavirus testing
is going watching the event it seemed
like it was april all over again
trump talking about developing rapid
tests
he had the same people including his
admiral talk about how the rapid tests
work mike pence spoke
and spoke and thanked uh trump for his
great leadership on coronavirus it was
like going back in time
six months as if the last six months
never even happened
but it was all a carefully crafted and
planned ruse to create the appearance
that donald trump isn't hiding but
getting him off stage
immediately without answering any
questions because of course the
questions would all be about
the insane bombshell tax return
revelations that donald trump has worked
for years to keep secret here is donald
trump
wrapping up the event without taking a
single
question and very importantly vaccines
are coming but we're rounding the corner
regardless
but vaccines are coming and they're
coming fast we have four great companies
already and
it's going to be added to very rapidly
uh they're
in final stages of testing and from what
we're hearing the
results are going to be very
extraordinary so uh
thank you very much i appreciate it and
thank you very much great job by abbott
right from the beginning great job by
abbott
thank you thank you very much everybody
thank you bye-bye everybody just going
to walk back into the white house
without answering any of the dozens and
dozens of pressing questions about
the insane allegations about me and like
any good trump event
trump struggled to speak not recognizing
the word hospice on his script and
calling it haas peace this is
odd 10 million for home health and
hospice care hospice care
agencies he just cannot get through one
of these without making a fool out of
himself here he is having a big
sort of dog and pony show having a
coronavirus test
done by the admiral for the cameras to
come up and demonstrate how
these tests are performed he'll do this
very nicely i think
good luck hope you don't test positive
funny guy right it's as if it's april
all over again
and we don't know how to test for
coronavirus but we're figuring it out
and it's news
that we have tests now you'll remember
the day before
yesterday at trump's press briefing when
people when reporters
tried to ask donald trump about the tax
stuff
he did anything he could not to answer
here he just scolded a reporter for
asking about his taxes when he had
called on somebody else
for being a rude person tell us what you
paid in federal time
i'm talking to him you should be more
respectful of this gentleman be very
rude to him
but i will tell you that i look forward
to releasing
that i look forward to releasing many
things i'm going to release many things
and people will be really shocked
trump will release lots of things and
people will be shocked well i'm
convinced i'm not worried anymore
trump also called the new york times
story about his taxes
fake news and is still claiming that he
just can't release anything because he's
under audit they are not releasing
they're not publishing the tax terms
they're not showing that out there
they're saying
to protect their sources in your tax
return sir does that sound right you're
paying a couple hundred dollars a year
of no income taxes
fake news it's totally fake news made up
fake
we went through the same stories you
could have asked me the same questions
four years ago i had to litigate this
and talk
about it totally fake news now
actually i paid tax but and you'll see
that
as soon as my tax returns are it it's
under order
they've been underwater for a long time
the irs does not treat me well they
treat me like the tea party like they
treated the tea party
they don't treat me well they treat me
very badly it's all
totally fake fake fake news eventually
trump is going to have to talk about
this right
i mean can trump i mean maybe he can you
tell me can trump really avoid questions
about this
through to the election on november 3rd
will chris
wallace tonight in the first debate
as the moderator will chris wallace
bring up the tax
situation if so i mean you have to
assume trump is going to be prepared
with
something in case taxes come up whether
people will buy it i
i don't know donald trump's former
personal lawyer michael cohen
is insisting that the tax stuff is
just the beginning of this type of thing
for donald trump and uh note that
when michael cohen testified months ago
was exactly right michael cohen
testified months ago
or was it a year ago i don't even
remember when it was at this point time
has flown by
but michael cohen testified trump will
artificially either inflate or deflate
the value of his assets
depending on what he's trying to achieve
and it turns out that he was right
here's michael cohen reminding us of
that
so joy let me start with what i know and
to which i testified before the house
oversight committee
in february of 2019. what i stated was
that trump fraudulently
inflated the value of his properties in
order to receive favorable terms from
lenders only then to under report their
value
for tax purposes basically what i did is
i called him our liar in cheat
that everything he says is a conflation
of the truth
and i finalize by saying that the
valuation of donald trump's assets
is so disproportionate to their real
worth
that we have no idea the true evaluation
of anything that he owns
i mean it's gaslighting to the extreme
trump has lied for so long about
literally
every facet of his life that the real
truth is
according to the new york times it's
it's shocking yeah
i started getting emails from people
saying
trump is going to pull out of tonight's
debate last minute because
it's just too risky given all of this
tax stuff
i still believe that the debate will
happen i hope that you'll be there with
me
if it does i will be live on youtube
twitch and facebook starting at 8 30 p.m
eastern time 5 30 p.m pacific don't miss
it
don't miss it we want it to be maybe
it'll be the most successful stream
we've ever done but we will all be
together for it
and we will see if this topic of the
taxes comes up i hope that it will
uh we will see if you are anything like
me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort
of your home it's a service called
steady md
they're one of our sponsors you take a
quiz you get matched with a licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steady steadymd.com pacman to take
the free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video